We Begin this NewsHour in Niger where
the deadline has expired for coup
leaders to step down and restore the
ousted president the West African block
ecowas has warned it could take would it
cause all necessary measures if
president bazoom is not released from
detention and reinstated niger's
military leaders remain defined they
have closed airspace and put border
forces on high alert they say ninja is
ready to defend itself and a warning
against any foreign aggression the
information concordance
according to the information we have
forces of a foreign power are preparing
an act of aggression against Niger and
its people in coordination with ecowas
and armed terrorist groups
faced with the threat of intervention
that is becoming clearer through
preparation from a neighboring country
niger's airspace is closed as of today
for all airports until further notice
any attempts to violate National
airspace will be met with an energetic
and instantaneous response
Minister has told his child is here that
there is still hope climatic resolution
to the crisis but he's also calling for
military intervention by ecowas of the
coup leaders refused to relinquish
control
can be a serious problem for the entire
region and the outcome will all depend
on the nature of the intervention this
is why I can say we should trust the
military experts from ecowas and the
mechanisms for this intervention that we
are expecting if they decide to go ahead
with that decision if a military
intervention doesn't take place a true
tragedy will happen in the region if
this coup succeeds
as you know three coups have happened in
West Africa and this will be the fourth
and if we let it succeed expect more
crews in the future Niger is technically
operating as a block that is standing
and defending the expansion of the Armed
groups towards the South we have two
correspondents covering the political
crisis in Niger Bennett Smith will have
the French reaction from Paris in just a
moment but let's bring in Charles
Stratford he's been following the
developments from the Senegalese Capital
Dakar we've heard from the Nigeria's
alstad prime minister talking about
what's at stake not just for Niger but
for ecowas II with that deadline now uh
Gone on Sunday Charles what are ecowas's
options
thank you
well what I think is important to
emphasize is that just because that
deadline has expired it by no means
means suggests that we're going to be
seeing any kind of immediate military
response from ecowas there are still a
lot of hurdles that echoas have to jump
over we understand that there are still
discussions going on looking for a
peaceful and diplomatic solution to this
crisis according to our sources in
Nigeria ecos are expected to hold a
special meeting on Thursday to further
discuss the crisis to explore all other
avenues other than that military option
that as you say would be a last resort
and we also know that echoas are facing
serious problems as well the respective
countries that could be part of some
sort of military intervention in trying
to get clearance green lights from their
respective legislative bodies their
parliaments for the deployment of troops
in any kind of mission we saw the last
couple of days a refusal by Nigeria's
Senate to to take up the president of
Nigeria's proposal of a deployment of
troops many senators in the Nigerian
Senate saying look
we don't want to be involved in any kind
of military intervention there's too
much at stake we've got too much on our
hands in dealing with groups like Boko
Haram and other armed groups operating
inside Nigeria and many analysts will
say look if Nigeria are having problems
getting their governments on board for
any kind of deployment then that spells
big difficulties potentially for other
governments governments like Ivory Coast
like guinea like sorry like Sierra Leone
like Liberia because without Nigeria
which is expected to take the lead in
any kind of potential military
intervention it's going to be very
difficult for anything like that to
actually happen but as I say we are
still quite a long way off that yet as
diplomatic efforts continue yeah and
very difficult because of the great
risks involved what are they Charles
well there are a whole host of risks I
think it's really important to recognize
as well what analysts constantly
pointing to and that is the level of
support for this coup inside Niger over
the last couple of days we've seen huge
crowds tens of thousands of coup
supporters gathering in the capital near
me so of course any kind of military
intervention there has massive risk a
reaction from those supporters and we've
had statements from the coup leaders in
Niger telling their supporters to
prepare for a potential military action
by echoas then of course there is the
risk of contagion of a spread of any
kind of intervention right the way
across the region because we already
know that Mali and Burkina Faso have
already said that any intervention
inside Niger by echoas would constitute
a declaration of war on those countries
too and interestingly there's been a
statement this morning put out by the
Malian military leaders saying that
there is a joint Burkina Faso and
marlindale allegation on its weight in
the Amy to show in their words
solidarity with the Niger coup leaders
and then of course there is the huge
risk of a deterioration of further
deterioration in security across the
region because of the the various armed
groups that operate there Al-Qaeda and
Isis these groups that have committed
attacks that have killed thousands of
people in the last decade or so and
basically forced Millions to flee their
homes and across borders so of course
this is very much on the minds of those
ecos officials as we understand these
discussions continue all right chance
thank you for that Charles Stratford
with the latest live in Dakar let's
bring in Bernard Smith now he's joining
us live from the French capital and
France watching developments very
closely Bernard what are they saying
France and the rest of Europe and the
United States watching developments very
closely France has suspended Aid
payments to bikino Faso and that is
after bikini Faso Mali both said that
they would consider any military
intervention in Niger as a declaration
of war on them as well so France trying
to use it to uh Aid muscle to punish in
a way bikino fasone Francis actually
just announced a suspension of flights
to wagadugu and Niger also has the runs
the risk of losing Aid if this military
coup continues the U.S has already
suspended development some development
Aid programs to Niger although it's
continuing with humanitarian programs
and all of that the French yeah the risk
of Nigeria of losing that development
Aid if the military intervention
continues all right Bernard thank you
for
Janet mcalligard is a former White House
official she says the role of ecowas has
changed over the past decades
it was supposed to be something akin to
you know what the Europeans have done it
was supposed to be about trade putting
down barriers and being a much more
united West African Bloc of 50 Nations
but it's become kind of a policeman
because things are rather difficult the
new president of ecowas of course is the
president of Nigeria which which shares
a border of about a thousand miles with
Niger so when you look at the
credibility you're looking at The
credibility also of Nigeria which has
000 troops so bringing troops in would
fall very much on the shoulders of the
Nigerians of which they've just taken
the chairmanship about a month ago